Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On November 16, 2004, 41-year-old Kanarinka Semyonowska contacted the local police station in Kichevo, a small city located in western Macedonia, to report her mother Mitra to be missing. The 64-year-old retired cleaner and housekeeper had left her home earlier that day for a trip to the market and hadn't been seen since. Kanarinka originally thought her mother may have gone to
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本期节目介绍。2004年11月16日，41岁的卡纳琳卡·谢苗诺夫斯卡联系了马其顿西部小城基切沃的当地警察局，报告她的母亲米特拉失踪了。这位64岁的退休清洁工和管家当天早些时候离开家去市场，之后就再也没有露面。卡纳琳卡最初认为她母亲可能是去
visit some family members after going to the market, but as time passed and Mitra failed to return home, her daughter's worry increased. An inspection of Mitra's house showed no signs of forced entry or anything to suggest the struggle had taken place, and there were no other clues to indicate where she may have gone. Kanarinka pressed the Kichevo police chief to launch an investigation into her mother's disappearance, but she was met with reluctance and a non-nerving sense that the police viewed her with suspicion. When they asked her to pay them money to conduct an investigation, a frustrated Kanarinka sought help elsewhere. She walked a hundred metres down the road from her mother's home to the house belonging to
探望去完市场后的家属，但随着时间推移，米特拉未能回家，她女儿的担忧与日俱增。对米特拉住所的检查没有发现强行闯入的迹象，也没有任何迹象表明发生过搏斗，并且没有其他线索表明她可能去了哪里。卡纳琳卡敦促基切沃警察局长对她母亲的失踪展开调查，但遭到了冷遇，并且有一种令人不安的感觉，即警察对她抱有怀疑。当他们要求她付钱才进行调查时，沮丧的卡纳琳卡转向别处寻求帮助。她顺着母亲家门前的路走了百来米，来到了属于
renowned freelance journalist Vlado Taneski. As the primary national news contact for the municipality of Kichevo, Vlado typically covered controversial political topics that plagued the region, ranging from police corruption to rising unemployment and illegal logging. While he had covered crime stories before, most were related to less serious issues like petty theft. Despite this, when Kanarinka Simianoska stopped by his house requesting he write an article about her mother's disappearance, Vlado agreed. When the article was published, it garnered local curiosity, but resulted in no leads. As days passed with no sign of Mitra, Kanarinka became increasingly worried that her mother had met with harm. Yet friends and neighbours held little concern,
著名自由撰稿记者弗拉多·塔内斯基的房子。作为基切沃市镇的主要国家新闻联络人，弗拉多通常报道困扰该地区的有争议的政治话题，从警察腐败到不断上升的失业率和非法砍伐。虽然他以前也报道过犯罪故事，但大多与小偷小摸等不太严重的问题有关。尽管如此，当卡纳琳卡·西米亚诺斯卡顺道来到他家请求他写一篇关于她母亲失踪的文章时，弗拉多答应了。文章发表后，引起了当地的好奇，但没有带来任何线索。随着米特拉失踪的日子一天天过去，卡纳琳卡越来越担心母亲遭遇了不测。然而朋友和邻居却不以为然，
as rumours speculated that Mitra probably ran away to escape a jealous boyfriend, or had simply relocated elsewhere and was safe and well. In the following weeks, Vlado Taneski continued to investigate Mitra's disappearance, scouting for information by interviewing her known acquaintances, but nothing worthwhile came to light. Mitra Simianoska had vanished without a trace. Almost two months later, on January 12, 2005, a scrap collector was scavenging through the neglected construction site of a sports stadium on the outskirts of Kichevo. As he foraged through the piles of junk and waste searching for anything of worth, he noticed something at the base of a steel construction frame. There, in a shallow hole
因为有谣言猜测米特拉可能是为了逃离一个嫉妒的男友而私奔了，或者只是搬到了别处，平安无事。在接下来的几周里，弗拉多·塔内斯基继续调查米特拉的失踪案，通过采访她认识的熟人来搜集信息，但没有发现任何有价值的线索。米特拉·西米亚诺斯卡就这样人间蒸发了。大约两个月后的2005年1月12日，一名废品收collection员正在基切沃郊外一个荒废的体育场建筑工地里搜寻废品。当他在成堆的垃圾和废弃物中搜寻任何有价值的东西时，他注意到一个钢铁建筑框架的底部有什么东西。在那里，在一个浅洞里
under a pile of rubbish and heavy stones, was a plastic garbage bag containing what appeared to be human remains. The Macedonian city of Kichevo is situated within the slopes of Bistro mountain. It offers little appeal for visitors, with its post-Yugoslavian buildings, crumbled sidewalks and bleak houses in desperate need of renovation. Most tourists don't bother stopping through, only glimpsing at sign on the journey south from Macedonia's capital of Skopje to Lake Okrid on the Albanian border. As was the case with most post-Yugoslavian states, the Macedonian government invested
在垃圾堆和重石之下，有一个塑料垃圾袋，里面装着疑似人类遗骸的东西。马其顿小城基切沃坐落于比斯特罗山的山坡上。它对游客几乎没有什么吸引力，那里有前南斯拉夫时期的建筑、残破的人行道和亟需翻修的荒凉房屋。大多数游客甚至懒得停留，在从马其顿首都斯科普里向南前往阿尔巴尼亚边境奥赫里德湖的旅程中，只是瞥一眼路标。正如大多数前南斯拉夫国家的情况一样，马其顿政府将
its money into more prominent and popular locales. This meant smaller towns and villages like Kichevo were often overlooked and forgotten, deteriorating quickly as they fell behind the fast-paced advances of modern life. Life was slow in Kichevo, where its 20,000 residents enjoyed a quiet and relatively peaceful existence, harboured by a close-knit community with strong traditional values. As such, Kichevo was rarely mentioned on national Macedonian news, but as word began to spread about the body found at the abandoned sports stadium, Kichevo was suddenly making national headlines. The chilling discovery shocked even the most hardened of Kichevo's local police officers, who were used to dealing with incidences of theft and domestic violence
资金投入到更显眼、更受欢迎的地方。这意味着基切沃这样较小的城镇和村庄常常被忽视和遗忘，随着它们落后于现代生活快节奏的发展而迅速恶化。基切沃的生活节奏很慢，其2万名居民享受着宁静且相对平和的生活，这得益于一个有着强烈传统价值观的紧密社区。因此，基切沃很少出现在马其顿国家新闻中，但随着关于在废弃体育场发现尸体的消息开始传开，基切沃突然登上了全国各大媒体的头条。这起令人毛骨悚然的发现震惊了基切沃最老练的当地警察，他们习惯了处理他们小镇上的盗窃和家庭暴力事件
in their small town, but rarely murder. The victim was soon identified as missing 64-year-old Mitra Semyonowska. Forensic testing revealed she had been brutally beaten, raped, tortured, and strangled to death, with telephone cords used to bind her legs together. Examiners calculated Mitra had only been deceased for approximately 10 days, meaning she was kept alive and tortured by her abductor for the two months she had been missing. Community fear had little time to manifest, as police soon announced that several arrests had been made in relation to the crime. Less than two weeks before Mitra's body was found, senior citizen Radislav Bozanowski was spending New Year's Eve alone at his house in Malkez,
但很少遇到谋杀案。这名受害者很快被确认是失踪的64岁妇女米特拉·谢苗诺夫斯卡。法医检测显示，她曾遭到残酷殴打、强奸、虐待和勒死，凶手用电话线将她的双腿捆绑在一起。检查人员推断米特拉死去仅约10天，这意味着她在失踪的两个月里一直被绑架者活着囚禁并折磨。社区的恐惧情绪还没来得及显现，警方就宣布已有多人与该罪行有关被捕。在米特拉的尸体被发现不到两周前，老者拉迪斯拉夫·博扎诺夫斯基正独自在马尔凯兹的家中过元旦，
a small village neighbouring Kichevo, when suddenly two men aged in their late 20s broke into his home under the influence of drugs and alcohol. Both assailants subjected Radislav to extreme acts of physical and sexual torture, before beating him to death and fleeing the scene in possession of nothing more than some loose change. The two perpetrators were promptly arrested and identified as Kichevo locals, Ante Rosteski and Igor Mercheski. When the remains of Mitra Semyonowska were discovered later that month, with wounds similar to those found on Radislav, a connection between the two murders was quickly established. This link was later confirmed during a police interrogation when Rosteski and Mercheski each confessed to both murders.
这是一个毗邻基切沃的小村庄。突然，两个二十多岁末的男子在药物和酒精的影响下闯入了她的家。两名袭击者对拉迪斯拉夫实施了极端的身心虐待，随后将他殴打致死，逃离现场时只拿走了一些零钱。这两名肇事者很快被捕，并被确认为基切沃本地人安特·罗斯特斯基和伊戈尔·梅尔切斯基。当米特拉·谢苗诺夫斯卡的遗骸于同月晚些时候被发现，且身上有与拉迪斯拉夫身上发现的类似的伤口时，这两起谋杀案之间的联系很快被建立起来。这一联系后来在一次警方审讯中得到证实，当时罗斯特斯基和梅尔切斯基分别对两起谋杀案供认不讳。
But by the time their trial commenced months later in 2005, Rosteski and Mercheski retracted their confessions in relation to Mitra Semyonowska's murder, denying any and all involvement. They claimed their confessions were false, given under duress after enduring severe beatings from interrogating police officers. Whilst both accused were able to provide exhaustive details about the crimes they committed against Radislav, they claimed to know nothing about what happened to Mitra. Furthermore, Ante Rosteski insisted he had a solid alibi for the day she went missing, as he had been working away from Kichevo at the time of her disappearance. Nevertheless, the judge found both of the accused guilty of double murder,
但在几个月后的2005年审判开始时，罗斯特斯基和梅尔切斯基翻供了，他们否认与米特拉·谢苗诺夫斯卡的谋杀案有任何及所有的牵连。他们声称自己的供词是虚假的，是在经受审讯警察的严厉殴打后在胁迫下做出的。虽然两名被告都能提供关于他们对拉迪斯拉夫所犯罪行的详尽细节，但他们声称对米特拉身上发生的事情一无所知。此外，安特·罗斯特斯基坚称他在她失踪那天有牢不可破的不在场证明，因为在她失踪期间他一直在基切沃以外的地方工作。尽管如此，法官裁定两名被告的双重谋杀罪名成立，
and Ante Rosteski and Igor Mercheski were each sentenced to life in prison. Given the disturbing nature of the two crimes in the otherwise peaceful city, the murder trial garnered intense interest from the national media. In the courtroom, the press bench was full of reporters scribbling notes as they listened to the prosecution, defence, and evidence provided by witnesses. Amongst the crowd was journalist Vlado Taneski, observing the sad conclusion to Mitra's story that he had personally been covering since she initially vanished. In his subsequent article about the trial for daily newspaper Nova Macedonia, titled, Surgical Gloves for a Monstrous Murder, Vlado wrote,
安特·罗斯特斯基和伊戈尔·梅尔切斯基因而被判处无期徒刑。鉴于这起在这个原本平静的城市中发生的两起令人不安的罪行的性质，这起谋杀案审判引起了国家媒体的极大兴趣。在法庭上，记者席坐满了沙沙记录的记者，他们聆听着控方、辩方以及证人提供的证据。人群中就有记者弗拉多·塔内斯基，他一直在观察米特拉故事的悲惨结局，而这个故事自她最初失踪以来他本人就一直在追踪报道。在他随后为日报《新马其顿报》撰写的关于审判的文章中，题为《为残忍谋杀戴上手术手套》，弗拉多写道：
In handcuffs and with surging eyes, 28-year-old Ante Rosteski and his friend Igor Mercheski, accused of a horrible double homicide in Kichevo and Malkets, walked into the courtroom. They stared vacantly at the ceiling and from time to time whispered, as if to themselves, it's all over, and now will pay for our crimes. In early November 2007, almost three years to the day since Mitra Semyonowska's abduction, 56-year-old cleaner Lubica Likowska left her house to buy groceries for lunch from a nearby supermarket. Two days later, she still hadn't returned home, and on November 12, Lubica's son, Ducco, filed a missing persons report with the local police.
28岁的安特·罗斯特斯基和他的朋友伊戈尔·梅尔切斯基戴着手铐，双眼充血，被控在基切沃和马尔凯茨犯下可怕的双重谋杀案，他们走进了法庭。他们茫然地盯着天花板，不时喃喃自语，仿佛在自言自语说，一切都结束了，现在我们要为我们的罪行付出代价。2007年11月初，几乎在米特拉·谢苗诺夫斯卡被绑架整整三年后，56岁的清洁工卢比卡·利科夫斯卡离开家，去附近的超市买午餐用的杂货。两天后，她依然没有回家，11月12日，卢比卡的儿子杜科向当地警方报了人口失踪。
As a word of Lubica's disappearance began to spread, investigators were at a loss, as there was nothing to suggest she had met with foul play. The 56-year-old was an upstanding citizen, a quiet, friendly woman who worked hard cleaning apartment buildings to support her family. Weeks passed, and with no sign of Lubica, Kichevo locals began to speculate over the similarities between her disappearance and the abduction of Mitra Semyonowska three years earlier. They were also reminded of yet another missing woman, 73-year-old Gorica Pavelska, a retired cleaner who was last seen five and a half years earlier on May 30, 2003. At the time of her disappearance, neighbors theorized that Gorica, who lived alone,
随着卢比卡失踪的消息开始传开，调查人员感到束手无策，因为没有任何迹象表明她遭遇了不测。这位56岁的老人是一位品行端正的公民，一个安静、友善的女人，她辛苦地擦洗公寓楼来养家糊口。数周过去了，依然没有卢比卡的踪影，基切沃当地人开始猜测她的失踪与三年前米特拉·谢苗诺夫斯卡被绑架案之间的相似之处。他们还想起了另一名失踪女性，73岁的戈里卡·帕维尔斯卡，她是一位退休清洁工，最后一次被人看到是在五年半前的2003年5月30日。在她失踪时，邻居们推测独自生活的戈里卡
had perhaps moved to Skopje to look for work without notifying anyone. Alternatively, some speculated she may have suffered a heart attack or stroke while on her own in a remote area. There was nothing at her apartment to suggest something untoward had happened. And her disappearance had been quickly pushed out of the public consciousness. But given what had happened since, Gorica's disappearance seemed far more sinister now. On February 3, 2008, her truck driver was passing through the Kichevo area on his way to the city of Gostjeva when he stopped at a roadside refreshment area near the Straja mountain range. As he gazed down into the surrounding ravine, something caught his eye.
也许在没有通知任何人的情况下搬到了斯科普里寻找工作。或者，一些人推测她可能在偏远地区独自一人时突发心脏病或中风。她的公寓里没有任何迹象表明发生了不好的事情。而且她的失踪很快就被公众淡忘了。但鉴于之后发生的事情，戈里卡的失踪现在看起来要险恶得多。2008年2月3日，她的卡车司机在前往戈斯特耶瓦市的途中经过基切沃地区时，在斯特拉哈山脉附近的一个路边休息区停了下来。当他凝视着周围的峡谷时，有什么东西引起了他的注意。
Sticking out from a rubbish-filled ditch was a human hand. Police were instantly notified, and an autopsy confirmed the body in the ravine was that of missing woman Lubica Lokoska. Forensic testing revealed the 56-year-old had been beaten, raped, and strangled to death. Her remains bound with telephone cords and wrapped in a plastic garbage bag. Lubica's death was calculated to have occurred just days before her body was discovered, indicating she was held captive for the three months she was missing. The similarities between the murders of Lubica Lokoska, Mitrosymyunoska, and, to a lesser extent, Rudislav Bozanowski, were too obvious to ignore. Especially for freelance journalist Vlado Taneski,
从一个垃圾填塞的沟渠里伸出一只人手。警方立刻得到通知，尸检证实峡谷中的尸体正是失踪妇女卢比卡·洛科斯卡。法医检测显示，这位56岁的老人遭到殴打、强奸和勒死。她的遗骸用电话线捆绑，并包裹在塑料垃圾袋中。经推算，卢比卡的死亡时间就在她尸体被发现前几天，这表明她在失踪的三个月里一直被囚禁。卢比卡·洛科斯卡、米特拉·西米尤诺斯卡以及在较小程度上拉迪斯拉夫·博扎诺夫斯基的谋杀案之间的相似之处太明显了，无法忽视。特别是对自由记者弗拉多·塔内斯基而言，
who had covered all cases extensively for local newspapers. Days later, on February 6, Vlado expressed his suspicions in an article for Macedonia's Morning Herald newspaper. He wrote, Rumours are bound. While the police are working on the case, the majority of people in Kichevo think that this murder is related to the double homicide of Mitrosymyunoska and Rudislav Bozanowski. He speculated over the possible scenarios that could have led to Lubica's abduction, putting forward the possibility that the attack may not have been premeditated. He suggested she may have been hit by a car, and instead of the driver coming to her aid,
他曾为当地报纸广泛报道过所有案件。几天后的2月6日，弗拉多在马其顿《晨报》的一篇文章中表达了他的怀疑。他写道：谣言四起。虽然警方正在处理此案，但基切沃的大多数人认为这起谋杀案与米特拉·西米尤诺斯卡和拉迪斯拉夫·博扎诺夫斯基的双重谋杀案有关。他推测了可能导致卢比卡被绑架的各种可能情况，并提出了袭击可能并非预谋的可能性。他暗示她可能被车撞了，而肇事司机不但没有伸出援手，
they saw it as an opportunity to take advantage of the situation. Weeks later, on the evening of May 7, 2008, 65-year-old Zivana Temalkoska, a retired janitor who now worked as a local cleaner, was sitting alone in her apartment when she received a startling phone call from a friend. They had been listening to local community radio station Canal 77 when they heard the news that Zivana's son, Zoran, had been involved in a car accident. Neighbours witnessed Zivana fleeing the apartment building with a worried expression on her face, walking at a fast pace in the direction of the hospital. In actuality, Zoran had not been involved in an accident and was perfectly fine. He returned home later that evening to
反而将其视为利用这一局势的机会。几周后的2008年5月7日傍晚，65岁的齐瓦娜·特马尔科斯卡独自坐在公寓里，她曾是一名退休门卫，现在做当地清洁工。这时她接到了一位朋友打来的令人震惊的电话。他们一直在收听当地社区广播电台77频道，当时他们听到消息称齐瓦娜的儿子佐兰遭遇了一场车祸。邻居们目睹齐瓦娜脸上带着担忧的表情跑出公寓楼，快步朝医院方向走去。事实上，佐兰并没有遭遇事故，他一切正常。当天晚些时候他回到家时，
find the apartment empty. When his mother failed to return home that night, Zoran questioned friends and neighbours, discovering the bizarre circumstances that led to Zivana fleeing the building. Worried, Zoran contacted police to report his mother missing, only to discover there had been no reported car accidents that evening. This revelation raised the likelihood that the radio broadcast about Zoran's accident was not done in error, but was an elaborate hoax to lure Zivana from her apartment by whomever was responsible for her disappearance. The next day, a woman walking on a street near the local kindergarten heard a ringing sound coming from nearby and followed the noise to a
发现公寓空无一人。当他的母亲当晚没有回家时，佐兰询问了朋友和邻居，发现了导致齐瓦娜逃离大楼的离奇情况。担心的佐兰联系警方报告母亲失踪，结果却发现当晚并没有接到车祸报警。这一披露增加了这样一种可能性：关于佐兰事故的广播并不是失误造成的，而是一个精心策划的骗局，目的是将齐瓦娜从公寓里引诱出来，而幕后黑手正是那些对她的失踪负责的人。第二天，一名女子在当地幼儿园附近的街道上行走时，听到附近传来手机铃声，她顺着声音找到了一个
discarded mobile phone lying in a patch of grass. She decided to answer the call and was startled when a police officer spoke to her, asking the woman to identify herself into ordering her to stay put. Police arrived on the scene and confirmed the mobile phone is belonging to Zivana Temelkoska. Given the location where the phone was found, police believed it had been thrown out of a moving vehicle. They were now convinced Zivana had met with foul play. On May 16, 2008, nine days after Zivana vanished, a passer-by had a soccer field on the outskirts of town made a disturbing discovery. Amongst the pile of rubbish, they found a plastic garbage bag containing the body of Zivana Temelkoska. The 65-year-old cleaner had been raped, tortured,
扔在草丛中的废弃手机。她决定接听电话，当听到一名警察对她说话时，她感到很惊讶。警察要求她表明身份并命令她原地待命。警察赶到现场，确认该手机属于齐瓦娜·特梅尔科斯卡。鉴于发现手机的地点，警方认为它是从行驶中的车辆中被扔出来的。他们现在确信齐瓦娜遭遇了不测。2008年5月16日，在齐瓦娜失踪九天后，一名路人在镇郊的一个足球场有一个令人不安的发现。在垃圾堆中，他们发现了一个塑料垃圾袋，里面装着齐瓦娜·特梅尔科斯卡的尸体。这位65岁的清洁工遭到强奸、虐待
and strangled, her body bound with telephone cords. Similarities were immediately drawn to the murders of Mitro Semyonoska in 2005 and Lubica Likoska just months earlier, with only one obvious difference. Unlike the other victims who had been found naked, Zivana was wearing a green polka dot nightgown, an item of clothing that did not belong to her. Further forensic examination revealed Zivana had likely been killed on the same day of her abduction. An autopsy revealed she had suffered multiple internal and external injuries, including five broken ribs, 13 knife wounds to the skull, and had endured violent sexual assault. Traces of Semyon found on Zivana's body were sent off at DNA testing as a police spokesperson
并被勒死，她的尸体被电话线捆绑。人们立刻将这起谋杀与2005年的米特拉·谢苗诺夫斯卡谋杀案以及几个月前的卢比卡·利科夫斯卡谋杀案联系起来，只有一个明显的区别。与其他被发现时赤身裸体的受害者不同，齐瓦娜穿着一件绿色波点睡裙，这件衣服不属于她。进一步的法医检查显示，齐瓦娜很可能是在她被绑架的当天被杀害的。尸检显示她遭受了多处体内外损伤，包括五根断肋骨、头骨上的13处刀伤，并经受了残酷的性侵犯。在齐瓦娜尸体上发现的精液痕迹被送去进行DNA检测，此时一名警方发言人
fronted the media, saying, we are talking about a violent death caused in an exceptionally monstrous way. Rumors that a serial killer was active in Kachevo presented a sensational news story. Vlado Taneski, who had been reporting on the string of murders from their outset, made the connection between victims by the killer's weapon of choice, a telephone cord which was then used to bind their bodies. A unique detail too specific to be a mere coincidence. On May 19, 2008, following the discovery of Zivana Temelkowska, Vlado Taneski wrote, the people of Kachevo live in fear and panic after another butchered body of a woman from the town was found this weekend. The local police and the citizens too see the mysterious
面对媒体说，我们谈论的是以极其残 monstruous（怪异/残暴）方式造成的暴力死亡。关于基切沃有连环杀手活跃的传言成为了一个轰动的新闻故事。弗拉多·塔内斯基从一开始就一直在报道这一连串的谋杀案，他通过凶手偏爱的凶器将受害者联系在一起：一根用于捆绑他们尸体的电话线。一个太具体而不能仅仅是巧合的独特细节。2008年5月19日，在发现齐瓦娜·特梅尔科斯卡之后，弗拉多·塔内斯基写道，本周末在发现该镇又一具被屠宰的女尸后，基切沃人民生活在恐惧和恐慌之中。当地警察和市民也认为神秘的
disappearance and hideous deaths of Zivana Temelkowska and Lubica Larkowska as an act of the same man, a serial killer. Police sources confirm the existence of a serial murderer in the town based on the fact that the women were tortured and killed in the same way, which eliminates the possibility that this was done by different people. The article explained that although investigators had interrogated several suspects, all had been released from custody shortly afterwards, meaning the killer was still at large. The journalist had then coined to the name the unknown killer would come to be known as, stating, the motives of the Kachevo monster remain unclear. The concept of a serial killer targeting the townspeople seemed so alien that even the
齐瓦娜·特梅尔科斯卡和卢比卡·拉尔科斯卡的失踪和可怕死亡是同一个人的行为，这是一个连环杀手。警方消息人士根据这些女性以相同方式遭受虐待和杀害这一事实，证实了镇上存在连环杀手的可能性，这排除了这是由不同人所为的可能性。文章解释说，尽管调查人员讯问了几名嫌疑人，但所有人不久后都获释了，这意味着凶手仍然在逃。这位记者随后创造了未知杀手日后为人所知的名字，并指出基切沃怪物的动机仍然不明。连环杀手将目标对准镇民的概念显得如此陌生，以至于连
mayor of Kachevo stated his disbelief, quote, we have seen something like that only in films, western films about serial killers. In our town, nobody could ever assume this could happen. But there it was, it happened, and right in our neighborhood too. Despite the fact that her killers had already been convicted, questions still remained as to whether or not Mitra Simeonowska could have been a victim of the Kachevo monster. Arntei Rosteski and Igor Murcheski continued to profess their innocence for her murder, insisting the confessions they provided in 2005 were false. Given Mitra's crime scene bore parallels to those of Lubica Larkowska and Zavana Temelkowska, who were abducted
基切沃市长也表达了不信，原话是：我们只在电影中看到过这样的事情，关于连环杀手的西部电影。在我们镇上，没有人会假设这会发生。但它确实发生了，而且就发生在我们的社区。尽管杀害她的凶手已经被定罪，但关于米特拉·西梅奥诺斯卡是否可能是基切沃怪物的受害者，仍然存在疑问。安特·罗斯特斯基和伊戈尔·默切斯基继续坚称他们对她的谋杀案是无辜的，坚称他们在2005年提供的供词是假的。鉴于米特拉的犯罪现场与卢比卡·拉尔科斯卡和扎瓦娜·特梅尔科斯卡（在罗斯特斯基和特梅尔科斯基服刑期间被绑架
and killed whilst Rosteski and Temelkowski were serving time in prison, her judge requested a review of Mitra Simeonowska's case. The subsequent inquiry exposed a major error in the original investigation when it was revealed that Semen obtained from Mitra's body at the time of her murder did not match either Rosteski or Murcheski's DNA. This critical information was known by investigators prior to the trial in 2005, but was never presented in court. Although police insisted this crucial DNA evidence had been passed on to all relevant parties at the time, including the public prosecutor, it soon became clear that the DNA results were intentionally withheld to ensure a speedy conviction for Mitra Simeonowska's brutal murder.
并被杀害）的有相似之处，她的法官要求对米特拉·西梅奥诺斯卡的案件进行复审。随后的调查暴露出最初调查中的一个重大错误，当时有透露称，在谋杀案发生时从米特拉尸体上获取的精液并不符合罗斯特斯基或默切斯基的DNA。这一关键信息在2005年审判前就被调查人员知晓，但从未在法庭上出示。尽管警方坚称这一关键的DNA证据当时已经传递给了所有相关方，包括公共检察官，但很快变得明朗的是，DNA结果被故意扣留，以确保米特拉·西梅奥诺斯卡的残酷谋杀案能得到迅速定罪。
Following this revelation, Arte Rosteski and Igor Murcheski were cleared for the wrongful conviction of the murder of Mitra Simeonowska, but remained incarcerated for the murder of Rudislav Bozanowski, which they continued to accept responsibility for. No one was held responsible for suppressing the DNA evidence that ultimately proved their innocence. The error became a major embarrassment for Kichevo police and the Justice Department. There are unethical actions enabling the Kichevo monster to continue to roam freely and harm others. With Mitra Simeonowska's murder officially revised to unsolved, the Semen sample found on her body was tested against the sample found on Zivana Temelkowska. While neither sample matched any known offenders within the criminal database,
在此披露之后，阿特·罗斯特斯基和伊戈尔·默切斯基洗清了对米特拉·西梅奥诺斯卡谋杀案的冤屈，但由于他们继续承担责任的拉迪斯拉夫·博扎诺夫斯基谋杀案，他们仍然被关押。没有人对隐瞒最终证明他们无辜的DNA证据承担责任。这一失误成为基切沃警察局和司法部门的一大尴尬。正是这些不道德的行为让基切沃怪物得以继续逍遥法外并伤害他人。随着米特拉·西梅奥诺斯卡的谋杀案被官方重新定性为未破悬案，在她尸体上发现的精液样本与在齐瓦娜·特梅尔科斯卡身上发现的样本进行了比对。虽然两个样本都不符合犯罪数据库中的任何已知罪犯，
the Semen found on both victims was confirmed to have come from the same perpetrator, expelling any doubts that a serial killer was at large. In a bid to catch the Kichevo monster, local law enforcement collaborated with the superiorly resourced Skopje police force to create a psychological profile of their suspect. They deduced he was likely a middle-aged male with a substantial physical strength required to restrain and strangle his victims before transporting their bodies. He had to be intimately familiar with Kichevo, and given there was no evidence of a struggle at any of his victims' homes or elsewhere, it was possible he was known and trusted by each woman.
但确认在两名受害者身上发现的精液来自同一名作案者，从而排除了存在连环杀手的任何疑虑。为了抓获基切沃怪物，当地执法部门与资源更优越的斯科普里警察局合作，制作了嫌疑人的心理侧写。他们推断他很可能是一个中年男性，具备制伏和勒死受害者并运送尸体所需的相当大的体能。他对基切沃必须非常熟悉，鉴于在任何受害者的家中或其他地方都没有挣扎的痕迹，他可能被每个女性所熟知和信任。
The abductions and subsequent slayings appeared to be planned in advance, suggesting the killer had a higher than average intelligence, while the similarities between each implied he was well organized. The killer's haphazard way of discarding his victims within city limits was explained by a police spokesperson who stated, whether it was three weeks or three years after they were murdered, the killer wanted the bodies to be found. The killer's preferred victim suggested he harboured sexual frustration towards older women that had likely stemmed from childhood trauma and developed into sadomasochistic desires. Although it couldn't be ruled out that the Kichevo monster had an accomplice, investigators believed he acted alone. The psychological profile
绑架和随后的谋杀似乎是提前计划好的，这表明凶手具有高于平均水平的智力，而每起案件之间的相似之处暗示他组织性极高。警方发言人解释了凶手在城市范围内随意抛弃受害者的做法，他指出：无论是她们被谋杀后三周还是三年，凶手都希望尸体被找到。凶手偏爱的受害者类型表明他怀有针对年长女性的性挫折感，这很可能源于童年创伤并发展成为虐恋欲望。虽然不能排除基切沃怪物有同伙的可能性，但调查人员相信他是单独作案。心理侧写
enabled police to narrow down their search, but a large pool of potential suspects remained. A much needed breakthrough in the investigation came when a jersey located near Zivana Temelkoska's body was found to contain traces of an unknown person's blood, opening up the possibility it belonged to her killer. Police had the blood sample tested to determine the blood type, allowing the suspect pool to be narrowed down further. Through a process of elimination, the number of suspects was whittled down to approximately 150 men. Each was brought in for police questioning and were eliminated one by one, bringing the list down to just 10 names. After verifying the alibis of the 10 remaining persons of interest, police were left with just
使警方能够缩小搜查范围，但潜在嫌疑人的基数仍然很大。调查中备受需要的突破口出现在人们发现齐瓦娜·特梅尔科斯卡尸体附近的一件运动衫上含有未知人员的血液痕迹，这开启了它属于她的凶手的可能性。警方对血液样本进行了检测以确定血型，从而使嫌疑人范围进一步缩小。通过排除法，嫌疑人数削减至大约150名男性。每个人都被带到警察局接受盘问并被一个接一个地排除，使名单缩减至仅仅10个名字。在核实了剩余10名重点关注对象的不在场证明后，警方只剩下
three likely suspects. DNA samples were taken from each, but would take days to be tested against evidence collected from the crime scenes. The comprehensive efforts undertaken by police were eagerly overseen by the media, including the main reporter responsible for covering the case, Vlado Taneski. In one newspaper article, he wrote, Several teams of police experts are working day and night in the field and the laboratory to establish the identity of the serial killer. Yet, unbeknownst to the press and public, investigators were already confident they had identified the Kachevo monster. On the afternoon of June 20, 2008, Ogden Charcharich, an editor for daily newspaper
三个可能的嫌疑人。从中提取了DNA样本，但需要几天时间才能与从犯罪现场收集的证据进行比对。警方开展的全面工作受到媒体的急切监督，包括负责报道此案的主力记者弗拉多·塔内斯基。在的一篇报纸文章中，他写道：多支警察专家小组正在实地和实验室夜以继日地工作，以确定连环杀手的身份。然而，在媒体和公众不知情的情况下，调查人员已经确信他们锁定了基切沃怪物。2008年6月20日下午，日报《新马其顿报》的编辑奥格登·恰尔查里奇
Novo Macedonia, received a phone call from one of his contacts at the Kachevo police department, advising that an arrest had been made in relation to the recent spade of murders. His contact wouldn't disclose the identity of the suspect in custody, but Ogden verified the information with the Ministry of the Interior, who confirmed it to be true. The Kachevo monster had been caught. Recognizing the breaking story presented his publication a huge opportunity, Ogden immediately grabbed his phone and called his go-to contact in Kachevo, award-winning freelance journalist Vlado Taneski. But much to his dismay, the call went unanswered. Ogden died again and again,
接到基切沃警察局一位线人的电话，通知说关于最近的一系列谋杀案已经实施了一起逮捕。他的线人没有透露拘留嫌疑人的身份，但奥格登向内政部核实了这一信息，内政部证实这是真的。基切沃怪物被抓获了。奥格登意识到这一突发新闻为他的出版物带来了巨大的机会，立刻抓起手机，打给了他在基切沃的首选联系人、屡获殊荣的自由记者弗拉多·塔内斯基。但令他沮丧的是，电话无人接听。奥格登一次又一次地打，
but still there was no response. This was highly out of character for Vlado, who was consistently reliable and always available when needed. Given that Vlado had been covering the case of the Kachevo monster since the beginning, it was even more unusual for him to be missing during the most significant moment of the entire investigation. Ogden's inability to reach Vlado Taneski led him to believe his star journalist was two steps ahead and had already learnt of the news and ventured to the police station to chase down a scoop. Ogden called the police station again, expecting to locate Vlado there, but was instead told by an officer, you don't have a reporter in Kachevo anymore.
但仍然没有回应。这极不符合弗拉多的一贯作风，他一向可靠，并且在需要时总能找到人。鉴于弗拉多从一开始就一直在报道基切沃怪物的案件，在整个调查最关键的时刻失联就更加不寻常了。奥格登联系不上弗拉多·塔内斯基，这让他觉得他的明星记者领先了两步，已经得知了消息并前往警察局去独家追踪新闻了。奥格登再次拨打警察局电话，期望在那里找到弗拉多，却被一名警官告知：你们在基切沃再也没有记者了。
Earlier that afternoon, dozens of police officers had closed in on an unassuming house in a quiet residential neighborhood of Kachevo. The house was typical of the area, a modern two-story building surrounded by fir trees and overgrown bushes, its metal window shutters half-drawn. Police entered the property and placed its owner, 56-year-old Vlado Taneski, under arrest for murder. Onlookers were left stunned as they watched the upstanding, soft-spoken and solitary journalist being led away in handcuffs. Unbeknownst to his editors, journalist Vlado Taneski had been a person of interest for the
当天下午早些时候，数十名警官包围了基切沃一个安静住宅区内的一栋不起眼的房子。这栋房子是该地区的典型代表，一栋现代化的两层建筑，周围环绕着冷杉树和杂草丛生的灌木，其金属窗板半拉着。警察进入房产，将房主、56岁的弗拉多·塔内斯基以谋杀罪逮捕。围观者们目瞪口呆地看着这位品行端正、轻声细语且独来独往的记者戴着手铐被带走。他的编辑们并不知道，记者弗拉多·塔内斯基其实从调查初期起就是该起杀戮案的
killing since early in the investigation and had been called in for police questioning multiple times. He fit the profile of the killer impeccably. The 56-year-old was tall and in good physical shape, lived alone in the same neighborhood as the murdered women and was known to each of them. Initial suspicions were cast upon Taneski when investigators noticed he had the uncanny ability to stay one step ahead of his journalistic rivals. He was able to write about the murders with a deep level of insight that included specific details police had intentionally withheld from the press. Taneski wrote that police had wrongfully convicted Arnte Rusteski and Igor Mercheski for Mitra Semyonowska's murder long before the case was reviewed and a DNA evidence confirmed
重点关注对象，并且曾被多次传唤接受警方盘问。他完美地符合凶手的侧写。这位56岁的男子身材高大，身体状况良好，独自住在被谋杀女性所在的同一个街区，并且她们每个人都认识他。最初的怀疑落在塔内斯基身上，是因为调查人员注意到他有一种不可思议的能力，总能比他的同行记者领先一步。他能够以一种深刻的洞察力撰写有关谋杀案的文章，其中包括警方故意向媒体隐瞒的具体细节。塔内斯基撰文称，警方早已错误地给安特·鲁斯特斯基和伊戈尔·梅尔切斯基定罪，指控他们谋杀米特拉·谢苗诺夫斯卡，而在该案被复审且DNA证据证实
their innocence. He was also the first person to publicly suggest the serial killer was responsible for the deaths of Mitra, Zivana and Lubica long before police had suggested the same. Additionally, Taneski speculated over the way in which Zivana Temelkowska had been abducted, specifying that she may have been coaxed from her house by false radio reports that her son had been involved in an accident. As a reporter, Taneski regularly submitted stories for inclusion on local radio news bulletins, ensuring he had the means to issue a false statement for broadcast. Suspicions directed towards Taneski were fully ignited when police noticed the seemingly offhand detail in an article he wrote for Nova Macedonia about Lubica Larkowska's murder.
他们无辜之前很久就已经这么做了。他也是第一个公开暗示连环杀手应对米特拉、齐瓦娜和卢比卡之死负责的人，比警方提出这一可能性的时间早得多。此外，塔内斯基还推测了齐瓦娜·特梅尔科斯卡被绑架的方式，具体说明她可能是通过虚假广播报道（称她的儿子遭遇了事故）被诱骗离开房屋的。作为一名记者，塔内斯基定期为当地电台新闻简报投稿，这确保了他有渠道发布虚假广播声明。当警方注意到他在《新马其顿报》上撰写关于卢比卡·拉尔科斯卡谋杀案的文章中看似漫不经心的细节时，对塔内斯基的怀疑被彻底点燃。
The monstrous murderer brutally tortured the helpless woman, killing her by strangling her with a telephone cord. The fact that a telephone cord was used as the killer's signature weapon was not publicly known at the time and had been strategically withheld by police to maintain the integrity of their investigation, a police spokesperson said. We read Taneski's stories and they made us suspicious. He knew too much. Following his arrest, Taneski insisted he didn't know any of the victims personally, a remark that only served to further arouse police suspicion. They were fully aware that Taneski lived in the same close-knit neighborhood as the murdered women and that each had been an associate of his late mother. Furthermore, Lubica Larkowska had
这个残暴的凶手残忍地虐待了这位无助的女性，用电话线将她勒死。凶手将电话线作为其标志性凶器这一事实当时并未公开，警方为了维护调查的完整性而战略性地隐瞒了这一点，一位警方发言人说：我们读了塔内斯基的故事，这让我们产生了怀疑。他知道得太多了。被捕后，塔内斯基坚称他不认识任何受害者，这番言论反而进一步引起了警方的怀疑。他们完全清楚塔内斯基和被谋杀的女性住在同一个紧密联系的街区，并且她们每个人都曾是他已故母亲的熟人。此外，卢比卡·拉尔科斯卡
previously worked as a cleaner for Taneski and the two had once worked together at the local metal factory. Taneski was held in police custody for 24 hours but refused to provide a statement. His answers to questions were evasive and he declined the invitation to contact a lawyer or advise anyone of his arrest. In the meantime, the results of his DNA testing came back. Three independent lab tests revealed Taneski's blood sample matched traces of semen found on Mitra Szymonowska and Zavana Temokowska as well as the bloodstained jersey found next to Zavana's body. Based on these discoveries, Vlado Taneski was formally charged with the murders of Mitra and Zavana. Initial DNA testing in relation to evidence obtained from Lubica Larkowska's crime
此前曾担任塔内斯基的清洁工，两人还曾在当地的金属工厂一起工作过。塔内斯基被警方拘留了24小时，但拒绝提供陈述。他对问题的回答含糊其辞，并拒绝了联系律师或将自己被逮捕的消息通知任何人的邀请。与此同时，他的DNA检测结果出来了。三次独立的实验室测试显示，塔内斯基的血液样本与在米特拉·西蒙诺夫斯卡和扎瓦娜·特莫科夫斯卡身上发现的精液痕迹，以及在扎瓦娜尸体旁发现的血迹斑斑的运动衫相匹配。基于这些发现，弗拉多·塔内斯基被正式指控谋杀米特拉和扎瓦娜。从卢比卡·拉尔科斯卡的犯罪
scene was inconclusive but forensic investigators initiated the examination of seven human hairs discovered at the dump site near her body. It would take a number of weeks before these results came back, giving police ample time to look into Vlado Taneski's history to learn what could have motivated the well-respected journalist to carry out such a brutal string of crimes. Born in Kachevo in 1952, Vlado Taneski was the middle child in a traditional Macedonian household with an older sister and younger brother. His father, Tryen, had fought in World War II before spending most of his adult life working as a night watchman in a timber factory. His mother, Gorica, worked as a cleaner at the local hospital. The couple were firm disciplinarians,
现场获取的证据进行的初步DNA测试没有得出确定结果，但法医调查人员开始对在她尸体附近的垃圾场发现的七根人类毛发进行检查。这些结果需要几周时间才能出来，这给了警方充足的时间来调查弗拉多·塔内斯基的历史，以了解是什么促使这位备受尊敬的记者实施了如此残酷的一系列罪行。弗拉多·塔内斯基1952年出生于基切沃，是一个传统马其顿家庭中的中间孩子，有一个姐姐和一个弟弟。他的父亲特里恩（Tryen）曾在二战中战斗，后来成年后的绝大部分时间都在一家木材厂担任夜间看门人。他的母亲戈里卡（Gorica）在当地医院担任清洁工。这对夫妇治家严格，
often resorting to corporal punishment to ensure their children's obedience. After his siblings left home, Vlado Taneski was left to care for his aging parents alone. He found a passion for journalism and politics that developed in his teenage years, where he served as the head of Kachevo's Communist Youth Organization. After graduating high school, he worked at a local metal factory, but his aspirations for journalism led him to go on and study at a political school in Croatia. At 21 years old, Taneski attended a regional poetry reading which was a huge success for the young writer. Not only did his poem win first place, he also met a striking young law student named Vesna. The two bonded over their love of
经常诉诸体罚以确保他们的孩子听话。在哥哥姐姐离家后，弗拉多·塔内斯基不得不独自照顾年迈的父母。他在十几岁时培养了对新闻和政治的热情，当时他担任基切沃共产主义青年组织的负责人。高中毕业后，他在当地的一家金属工厂工作，但他对新闻业的追求促使他前往克罗地亚的一所政治学校深造。21岁时，塔内斯基参加了一个地区诗歌朗诵会，这对年轻的作家来说是一个巨大的成功。他的诗不仅赢得了第一名，他还遇到了一位迷人的年轻法学学生维斯纳（Vesna）。两人因对
literature and began dating soon after, deciding to get married four years later. Days before their wedding, Vesna's family were in a car accident which claimed the lives of both her father and brother. She survived the ordeal, but the trauma led her to suffer from depression throughout the remainder of her life. Although this didn't stop her from fulfilling her goals and she went on to complete her law degree, becoming the first female lawyer in Kachevo. At the same time, her husband began working at the local radio station before securing a position as a full-time reporter for the largest daily newspaper in the country, Nova Macedonia. Although theirs was a supportive marriage, it had issues from the start, stemming from Vesna's conservative
文学的热爱而结缘，不久后开始约会，并在四年后决定结婚。在他们婚礼前几天，维斯纳的家人遭遇了一场车祸，夺去了她父亲和兄弟的生命。她从这场劫难中幸存下来，但创伤导致她在余生中一直饱受抑郁症的困扰。尽管这并没有阻止她实现自己的目标，她继续完成了法律学位，成为了基切沃的第一位女律师。与此同时，她的丈夫开始在当地广播电台工作，后来在国家最大的日报《新马其顿报》担任全职记者。尽管这是一桩互相支持的婚姻，但由于维斯纳保守
and authoritarian in-laws. She'd watch her husband as he often clashed with his parents, turning his typically gentle demeanor into one of agitation and aggression. Whenever Vesna voiced her issues about her mother-in-law, Taneski always sided with his mother. Other than these issues, the pair had a relatively happy marriage and were well respected within their community. They had two sons who grew up to establish successful careers as academics and doctors, with Taneski taking on the role of a helpful and supportive father. The Taneski's owned a secluded summer cottage five kilometers from Kachevo, where the family's aging patriarch, Trion, chose to spend a majority of his golden years,
且专制的公婆，从一开始就存在问题。她常常看着丈夫与父母发生冲突，将他原本温和的性格变得焦躁和具有攻击性。每当维斯纳表达对婆婆的不满时，塔内斯基总是站在母亲一边。除了这些问题之外，两人的婚姻相对幸福，在社区中也备受尊重。他们有两个儿子，长大后都在学术界和医学界建立了成功的职业生涯，塔内斯基则扮演了一个乐于助人且支持性强的父亲角色。塔内斯基夫妇在离基切沃五公里处拥有一个偏僻的避暑小屋，家里的老家长特里恩选择在那里度过他大部分的晚年，
tending to his vegetable gardens and raising goats in solitude. The ramshackle-ult cottage was surrounded by cornfields in the middle of nowhere, which suited the elderly man perfectly. Then in August 2002, Trion was found dead in the cottage, with his death rumoured to have been the result of suicide. Following Trion's death, things only went downhill for the family. In December 2002, just four months after the death of her husband, Matriarch Godritsa took an accidental overdose of sleeping pills and passed away in the family home. The sudden deaths of his parents introduced financial problems to Vladotaneski's life, as he no longer received income from their pensions to help with the bills.
孤独地照料他的菜园和养山羊。这个破旧的小屋四周环绕着玉米地，地处荒凉，非常适合这位老人。接着在2002年8月，特里恩被发现死在小屋里，传言他的死是自杀的结果。在特里恩死后，这个家庭的情况急转直下。2002年12月，就在她丈夫去世仅仅四个月后，老母亲戈德里察（Godritsa）意外服用过量的安眠药，在家里去世了。父母的突然离世给弗拉多·塔内斯基的生活带来了财务问题，因为他不再能收到他们退休金的收入来帮助支付账单。
To make matters worse, in 2003, the newspaper he had been employed by for 20 years, Nova Macedonia was also experiencing financial hardship, and as a result, he was laid off from his full-time position. After starting work as a freelance writer for several publications, Taneski was paid on commission, but without the stable income, the responsibility of financially supporting their family lay on his wife's shoulders. In 2004, the Ministry of Education offered Vesna a promotion to the position of University Inspector, a career advancement which meant she would have to relocate to Skopje, the country's capital. Vesna bought an apartment close to her new workplace, while her husband remained in Kachevo
更糟糕的是，在2003年，他工作了20年的报社“新马其顿报”也遭遇了财务困境，结果他被全职岗位解雇了。在开始为多家出版物担任自由撰稿人后，塔内斯基按件计酬，但在没有稳定收入的情况下，养家糊口的责任落在了他妻子的肩上。2004年，教育部向维斯娜提供了一次晋升机会，担任大学督察，这一职业发展意味着她将不得不搬到该国的首都斯科普里。维斯娜在她的新工作地点附近买了一套公寓，而她的丈夫则留在了基切沃
alone, planning to join her in Skopje when the timing was right. In the meantime, Taneski gained a technical qualification and opened a local air conditioning store to ensure he was bringing in regular income. Vesna regarded her husband as a progressive thinker who was far too ambitious to waste his talents in the small town of Kachevo, but he strongly preferred the quiet, provincial way of life. Taneski believed capitalism, Western ideals, and the open market economy were destroying the traditions of his country, and he longed for the time before Macedonia's independence from Yugoslavia. Those ideals spilled into his writing, where he wrote long nostalgic articles romancing the Macedonian countryside, glorifying manual labour and the rural lifestyle.
独自一人，计划在时机成熟时去斯科普里与她会合。在此期间，塔内斯基取得了技术资格证书，并开了一家当地的空调店，以确保自己有稳定的收入来源。维斯娜认为她的丈夫是一个思想进步的人，他的野心太大了，不应该把才华浪费在基切沃这个小镇上，但他却强烈倾向于安静的省城生活方式。塔内斯基认为资本主义、西方理想和开放的市场经济正在摧毁他国家的传统，他渴望马其顿脱离南斯拉夫独立之前的时代。这些理想渗透到了他的文章中，他写了许多怀旧的长篇文章，浪漫化马其顿的乡村，美化体力劳动和农村生活方式。
Many regarded Taneski's writing as outdated, and there were conflicting views about his journalistic style in a country intent on keeping up with modern times. While there didn't seem to be much interest in his whimsical, long-form prose, Taneski was committed to succeeding in the career he'd worked a lifetime to establish. When the Kachevo monster began his reign of terror, Vlado Taneski secured himself as the lead reporter on the case, interviewing friends and family of the victims whilst writing up stories for several major publications, ensuring his content received nationwide coverage. When Mitro Semyonowska disappeared, Taneski agreed to write an article about the case on behalf of her daughter, Kana Rinka.
许多人认为塔内斯基的文章已经过时，在一个决心跟上时代步伐的国家里，人们对他的新闻风格有着矛盾的看法。虽然人们对他的异想天开的长篇散文似乎没有太大兴趣，但塔内斯基致力于在他花了一生时间建立的职业生涯中取得成功。当基切沃怪物开始他的恐怖统治时，弗拉多·塔内斯基确保了自己成为该案的首席记者，采访了受害者的朋友和家人，同时为几家主要出版物撰写报道，确保他的内容得到全国范围的报道。当米特罗·塞米奥诺夫斯卡失踪时，塔内斯基同意代表她的女儿卡娜·琳卡写一篇关于这个案件的文章。
Yet, even after two men were convicted for Mitro's murder, Taneski inexplicitly continued to investigate and report on the crime. When Lubica Lakoska disappeared, Taneski met with her worried family and sat with her sister as she described Lubica as quiet and gentle, details he later used in his articles on The Missing Woman. Lubica's sister later stated, I never suspected that he was the murderer, I knew him as a good, honest person. We weren't close at all, but we were neighbours. Taneski doorknocked to the area when Zavana Temalkoska disappeared, again interviewing neighbours, relatives and law enforcement before publishing his findings in articles on the crime.
然而，即使在两名男子被判定犯有谋杀米特罗的罪行之后，塔内斯基仍然莫名其妙地继续调查和报道这起犯罪。当卢比卡·拉科斯卡失踪时，塔内斯基会见了她担心的家人，并和她的姐姐坐在一起，听她形容卢比卡安静而温柔，这些细节后来被他用在他关于《失踪女性》的文章中。卢比卡的姐姐后来表示：“我从来没有怀疑过他是凶手，我认识他是一个善良、诚实的人。我们一点也不亲近，但我们是邻居。”当扎瓦纳·泰马尔科斯卡失踪时，塔内斯基挨家挨户地走访了该地区，再次采访了邻居、亲戚和执法人员，然后将他的调查结果发表在关于这起犯罪的文章中。
Her son Zoran stated, When my mother disappeared, Taneski asked me questions. Even when he met me in the street, he'd inquire if I had news or if I suspected anyone in particular. We were neighbours for a long time, knew each other for years, so it never even crossed my mind that he might be the guilty one. Upon learning that police had arrested the journalist in relation to his mother's murder, Zoran said, You can't describe the feeling, it was very hard on me, to have someone kill your mother and then come to your house to say hi.
她的儿子佐兰表示：“我母亲失踪时，塔内斯基问了我一些问题。甚至当他在街上遇到我时，他也会打听我是否有消息，或者我是否怀疑任何人。我们做了很长时间的邻居，认识好多年了，所以我从来没有想过他可能是罪魁祸首。”在得知警方因他母亲的谋杀案逮捕了这名记者后，佐兰说：“你无法形容那种感觉，对我来说太难了，有人杀害了你的母亲，然后又来到你家打招呼。”
It's horrifying. Thorough searches of Vlado Taneski's properties uncovered a collection of pornographic videos and magazines at his family's remote summer cottage, along with various ropes and cords. Items of clothing and shoes belonging to the victims were also found at the cottage, leading police to speculate he had held the women captive at his property, where they were brutally tortured and sexually abused over an extended period of time, before he killed them and disposed of their bodies. Vesna stood by her husband and insisted the items of clothing in question belonged to her
这太可怕了。对弗拉多·塔内斯基住所的彻底搜查发现，在他家人偏远的避暑别墅里有一堆色情录像带和杂志，还有各种绳索。在别墅里还找到了属于受害者的衣物和鞋子，这让警方推测他将这些女性囚禁在自己的物业里，在那里她们在很长一段时间里遭到残酷的折磨和性虐待，然后他杀害了她们并处理了她们的尸体。维斯娜坚定地支持她的丈夫，并坚称有问题的衣物属于她
late mother-in-law. Yet, the green polka dot nightgown, Zovana Temelkoska was wearing at the time her body was discovered, was believed to have once belonged to Vlado Taneski's mother, indicating a possible connection between the murders and Taneski's maternal relationship. Adding to this theory was the fact the victims shared many similarities with his mother, Godritsa Taneski, in that they were of similar age, appearance, and held the same job as a cleaner. When interviewed for the documentary series Evil Up Close, British psychologist Emma Short explained to the likelihood that Taneski had selected his victims based on their similarities to his mother. Considering the murder spree had begun after his mother's death,
已故的婆婆。然而，佐瓦娜·泰梅尔科斯卡被发现尸体时穿的绿色波点睡裙，据信曾经属于弗拉多·塔内斯基的母亲，这表明谋杀案与塔内斯基的母子关系之间存在可能的联系。更支持这一理论的是，受害者与他的母亲戈德里萨·塔内斯基有许多相似之处，她们年龄相仿，外表相似，并且都从事清洁工的工作。在接受纪录片系列《近距离恶魔》采访时，英国心理学家埃玛·肖特向观众解释了塔内斯基根据与他母亲的相似之处来选择受害者的可能性。考虑到杀戮狂潮是在他母亲去世后开始的，
it was possible Taneski's desire to kill was linked to the loss. Emma Short, quote, He was clearly very strongly attached to her, but a strong attachment to a parent doesn't always mean love. Sometimes it can mean hate or resentment, but those things are just as powerful as love. The day after Taneski was placed under arrest, the Ministry of Interior released a public statement announcing that Kachevo Monster had finally been caught. Vlado Taneski's full name was released, along with details about his occupation, and a list of the evidence so far collected against him. The revelations sent shockwaves throughout the country. Macedonia's Morning Herald newspaper broke the major news story,
塔内斯基杀戮的欲望可能与这种失去有关。埃玛·肖特说：“他显然对她有着非常强烈的依恋，但对父母的强烈依恋并不总是意味着爱。有时它可能意味着恨或怨恨，但这些东西和爱一样强大。”在塔内斯基被捕的第二天，内政部发布了一份公开声明，宣布基切沃怪物终于落网。弗拉多·塔内斯基的全名被公布，同时公布的还有他的职业细节，以及迄今为止收集到的针对他的证据清单。这一爆料在全国引起了轩然大波。马其顿的《晨报》打破了这一重大新闻，
which was unlike any the media or public had ever heard before. The article read, Is it possible that around the family lived such a killer, who was hiding so skillfully behind the mask of loyal and faithful husband, proud father, gentle son-in-law, and exemplary son? Many refused to believe the allegations, with speculation rife that police had framed Taneski due to his intricate coverage of the case, which pointed out the many failings of Macedonian law enforcement throughout the investigation. In an interview with Esquire magazine, a close friend and former colleague of Taneski's described his friend of 20 years as shy, humble, and unobtrusive. Quote,
这与媒体或公众以前听过的任何新闻都不同。文章写道：“难道家里可能住着这样一个杀手，他如此巧妙地隐藏在忠诚的丈夫、骄傲的父亲、温柔的女婿和模范儿子的面具背后吗？”许多人拒绝相信这些指控，猜测警方因为塔内斯基对案件的深入报道而陷害了他，这篇报道指出了马其顿执法部门在整个调查过程中的许多失误。在接受《时尚先生》杂志采访时，塔内斯基的一位密友兼前同事将这位相识20年的朋友形容为害羞、谦逊和不引人注目。他说，
I never felt there was any aggression, anger, or inhumanity within him. Vlado just seemed completely normal. When I heard that he was accused of being the serial killer, it was as if a lightning had struck me. In an article for the Financial Times, one of Taneski's former editors stated, To say that I was gobsmacked is an understatement. I was speechless. I was shaking. I couldn't believe he was the serial killer, and part of me still doesn't believe it. Even relatives of the Kachevo monsters victims were uncertain whether to believe the news. Lubica Larkovskaya's sister said she could never have suspected Taneski was the murderer, as she had only known him to be a good and honest person. Although, not everyone remembered him
“我从未觉得他身上有任何侵略性、愤怒或不人道。弗拉多看起来完全正常。当我听说他被指控为连环杀手时，简直就像一道闪电击中了我和。”在为《金融时报》撰写的一篇文章中，塔内斯基的一位前编辑表示：“说我惊呆了，那是轻描淡写。我当时说不出话来。我在发抖。我不敢相信他是连环杀手，我的一部分现在仍然不相信。”甚至基切沃怪物受害者的亲属也不确定是否该相信这个消息。卢比卡·拉尔科夫斯卡娅的姐姐说，她永远不会怀疑塔内斯基是凶手，因为她只知道他是一个善良和诚实的人。虽然，并不是每个人都记得他
that way. One neighbour described Taneski as a mysterious, silent man who never said so much as hello throughout his entire life. Another neighbour recalled him to be strange and antisocial. Vlado Taneski was ordered to remain in police custody for a 30-day detention period before legal proceedings commenced. He was assigned a public defender and transferred to a prison in Tatovo, a town located 70 kilometres north of Kachevo. Upon his admission to prison, a medical review declared him to be of good health. A prisoner accused of crimes as serious as Taneski's was expected to be treated carefully and provided with their own cell. However, like most of the jails in Macedonia at the time, Tatovo prison was severely overcrowded.
是那样的。一位邻居将塔内斯基描述为一个神秘、沉默的人，他一生中从未说过一句问候的话。另一位邻居回忆说他很奇怪而且反社会。弗拉多·塔内斯基被命令在警方拘留所接受为期30天的拘留，然后才能开始法律程序。他被指派了一名公设辩护人，并被转移到塔托沃的一所监狱，该镇位于基切沃以北70公里处。在他入狱时，一份医疗审查宣布他身体健康。像塔内斯基这样被指控犯有如此严重罪行的囚犯，本应受到谨慎对待并被提供自己的单人牢房。然而，就像当时马其顿的大多数监狱一样，塔托沃监狱严重过度拥挤。
Taneski was placed into the only space available, a tiny cell consisting of two bunk beds and a grimy bathroom containing a toilet, sink and a large bucket. The small cell already housed three inmates, two men in their 20s who had been charged for meddling in the recent parliamentary election and a 49-year-old awaiting trial for poisoning a 14-year-old girl. Severe water restrictions meant taps were turned off during the day and inmates were instead provided with bottles of drinking water and plastic buckets to use for personal hygiene. These restrictions occurred during daytime hours only and weren't enforced during the night. On June 23, 2008, three days after Taneski's arrest, one of his cellmates awoke to the sound
塔内斯基被安置在唯一可用的空间里，这是一间极小的牢房，里面有两张双层床和一个肮脏的浴室，里面有一个马桶、洗手间和一个大桶。这个小牢房里已经住了三名犯人，其中两名20多岁的男子因干涉最近的议会选举而被起诉，还有一名49岁的男子正在等待审判，罪名是毒害一名14岁女孩。严格的用水限制意味着白天水龙头是关着的，犯人们会得到瓶装饮用水和塑料桶用于个人卫生。这些限制仅在白天实行，夜间不强制执行。2008年6月23日，在塔内斯基被捕三天后，他的一个同牢室友在凌晨2点前不久被声音惊醒
of running water just before 2 a.m. The prisoner went into the bathroom and found Taneski on his knees with his arms by his side, face down in a bucket of dirty water. Correction officers rushed into the cell, but attempts to resuscitate him were unsuccessful. By the time a doctor arrived, Vlado Taneski was dead. A search of his body revealed three items inside his pockets, a round-trip train ticket from Kachevo to Skopje, a blister pack of the antidepressant medication peroxatine and a note directing authorities to check under the pillow on his bed. There, they found a second note, which read, I am proud of my family and I love them very much. I have not done any of the things I am accused of.
流水声刚刚在凌晨2点前响起。这名囚犯走进浴室，发现塔内斯基双膝跪地，双臂垂在身旁，脸朝下趴在一桶脏水里。惩教官员冲进牢房，但恢复心跳的尝试没有成功。当医生到达时，弗拉多·塔内斯基已经死了。对他的尸体进行的搜查在他的口袋里发现了三件物品，一张从基切沃到斯科普里的往返火车票，一板抗抑郁药物帕罗西汀，以及一张指示当局检查他床头枕头底下的便条。在那里，他们发现了第二张便条，上面写着：“我为我的家人感到骄傲，我非常爱他们。我没有做过任何我被指控的事情。”
I did not commit these murders. A subsequent autopsy of Taneski's body found the presence of water in his lungs, confirming drowning to be his cause of death. Other than a small bruise on his forehead, which was sustained whilst his body spasmed during the drowning, there were no other signs of violence or defensive injuries to suggest foul play was involved. Testing of the water in the bucket revealed no traces of sedatives, chemicals or poisons. The prisoner's governor confirmed Taneski had not been behaving suspiciously or raised any cause for concern in the day prior to his death. He communicated well with his cellmates, ate all of his meals and acted normally.
“我没有犯下这些谋杀案。”随后对塔内斯基尸体进行的尸检发现他的肺部有水，证实死因是溺水。除了他额头上的一个小瘀伤（这是在他溺水时身体痉挛时受到的）之外，没有其他暴力迹象或防卫伤来表明涉及谋杀。对桶中水的检测没有发现镇静剂、化学物质或毒物的痕迹。监狱长证实，在死前的一天里，塔内斯基的行为并不引人注目，也没有引起任何担忧。他与同牢室友沟通良好，吃完了所有的饭菜，表现得很正常。
There were no marks or injuries on any of Taneski's cellmates to suggest that they could have been involved in his death in any way. During their attempts to resuscitate Taneski, prison guards had dragged him from the cell into a hallway, contaminating the scene. Without knowing specific facts like the exact positioning of Taneski's body at the time of his death, an inquest concluded the journalist had voluntarily ended his own life. A police spokesperson stated, he put his head in a pail full of water. He ended his life like in a horror movie. Under Macedonian criminal law, the prosecution of a deceased person is not permitted, meaning there would be no further legal proceedings against Vlado Taneski.
塔内斯基的任何同牢室友身上都没有伤痕或伤口，表明他们可能以任何方式参与了他的死亡。在试图让塔内斯基恢复心跳的过程中，狱警把他从牢房拖到走廊里，破坏了现场。在不知道具体事实（如塔内斯基死时身体的确切位置）的情况下，死因裁判官得出结论，这名记者是自愿结束了自己的生命。一名警方发言人说：“他把头放进了一桶水里。他像在恐怖电影里一样结束了自己的生命。”根据马其顿刑法，对已故人员的起诉是不被允许的，这意味着将不再对弗拉多·塔内斯基进行进一步的法律程序。
Given the highly unusual way that Taneski had chosen to end his life, conspiracy theories ran rife that implicated police in his death, with claims that correction officers had purposely sabotaged the crime scene to hinder any further investigations. Some of the wilder theories suggested the journalist had been a victim of waterboarding from officials, desperate to extract a confession. Some started to speculate that government officials had framed Taneski for the murders and orchestrated his death, with his DNA either planted or falsified to ensure the case was solved quickly, as with the botched conviction of Ante Rosteski and Igor Macheski. Although this seemed highly unlikely given the Republic of Macedonia aimed to join
鉴于塔内斯基选择结束自己生命的方式非常不寻常，阴谋论满天飞，暗示警方参与了他的死亡，并声称惩教官员故意破坏了犯罪现场以阻碍进一步调查。一些更离谱的理论暗示，这名记者一直是官员水刑的受害者，官员们迫切希望从中逼出口供。一些人开始推测，政府官员陷害了塔内斯基并精心策划了他的死，他的DNA被栽赃或伪造，以确保案件迅速解决，就像对安特·罗斯特斯基和伊戈尔·马切斯基的拙劣定罪一样。尽管考虑到马其顿共和国的目标是加入
the European Union and any further significant failures of their judicial system would reflect poorly on the developing country, the Macedonian government had much more to gain from conducting a fair trial of the accused serial killer and delivering a verdict based on the presentation of fair and factual evidence. The conspiracy theories reached political level, with several journalists criticising Macedonia's executive and judicial power. They blamed the Ministry of Interior for revealing Vlado Taneski's identity on national television the day following his arrest, an act they believed compromised the possibility of him receiving a fair trial. The entire investigation against Taneski was heavily scrutinised, including the fact that no
欧洲联盟，其司法体系的任何进一步重大失业都会对这个发展中国家产生负面影响，因此这种可能性微乎其微。马其顿政府从对被指控的连环杀手进行公正审判并根据公正和真实的证据提出裁决中获得的利益要大得多。这些阴谋论上升到了政治层面，几位记者批评了马其顿的行政和司法权力。他们指责内政部在塔内斯基被捕的第二天在国家电视台公布了他的身份，他们认为这一举动危及了他获得公正审判的可能性。针对塔内斯基的整个调查受到了严格审查，包括以下事实：
witnesses were present when key evidence was collected from his home and the remote summer cottage where his victims were allegedly imprisoned. Two weeks after Vlado Taneski's death, the DNA test results for the seven hairs found near Lubica Likovska's body were in, revealing they belonged to Taneski. A police spokesperson said, All these women were raped, molested and murdered in the most terrible way, and we have very strong evidence that Taneski was responsible for all three. In the end, there were many things that pointed to him as a suspect that led us to file charges against him for two of the murders. We were close to charging him with a third murder and hoped he would give us details of a fourth
从他的家以及据称囚禁受害者的偏远避暑别墅收集关键证据时，没有证人在场。弗拉多·塔内斯基死后两周，在卢比卡·利科夫斯卡尸体附近发现的七根头发的DNA测试结果出来了，表明它们属于塔内斯基。一名警方发言人说：“所有这些女性都以最可怕的方式被强奸、虐待和谋杀，我们有非常强力的证据证明塔内斯基对这三起案件负有责任。最后，有很多迹象表明他是一个嫌疑人，导致我们对其中两起谋杀案对其实施了指控。我们差点以第三起谋杀案起诉他，并希望他能向我们提供第四名女性的细节”，
woman who disappeared in 2003 because we believe he was involved in that case too. The fourth woman was 73-year-old Gordytsa Pavelska, the retired cleaner who hadn't been seen since May 2003. Whether or not Taneski was involved with her disappearance would now likely never be determined. Her whereabouts remain unknown. Members of the public continue to form strong opinions on the matter. Macedonia's leading criminologist Marijan Kotevski called Taneski's suicide balanced and tendentious, saying the only person who had anything to gain from Taneski's death was Taneski himself. He believed that when faced with the evidence, Taneski had cautiously examined all the pros and cons of his situation and chose a mysterious outcome that would ensure he
这名女性于2003年失踪，因为我们相信他也卷入了那起案件。第四名女性是73岁的戈迪萨·帕维尔斯卡，这位退休清洁工自2003年5月以来就再也没有露面。塔内斯基是否参与了她的失踪，现在可能永远无法确定了。她的下落依然不明。公众继续对这件事形成强烈的看法。马其顿首席犯罪学家马里扬·科捷夫斯基称塔内斯基的自杀是平衡且有倾向性的，并表示唯一能从塔内斯基之死中获益的人就是塔内斯基自己。他认为，当面对证据时，塔内斯基仔细权衡了他处境的所有利弊，并选择了一个神秘的结果，以确保他
avoided the embarrassment of a public trial while causing people to question his guilt, therefore protecting his family from disgrace. Using great willpower, Marijan Kotevski believed it was very possible that Taneski had overcome his biological reflexes to gasp for air, and he was able to keep his head underwater until he eventually passed out and died. Another controversial issue surrounding Taneski's suicide was the peroxatine tablets found in his pockets at the time of his death. The main ingredient in this medication is a selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor, or SSRI, which is used to treat depression, anxiety, and post-traumatic stress disorder. Although peroxatine is a popular drug with many health benefits when administered
避免了公开审判的尴尬，同时让人们对他的清白产生疑问，从而保护他的家人免受耻辱。马里扬·科捷夫斯基认为，凭借强大的意志力，塔内斯基很有可能克服了渴望空气的生物反射，他能够把头保持在水面下，直到最终昏迷并死亡。围绕塔内斯基自杀的另一个争议问题是，在他死时口袋里发现了帕罗西汀药片。这种药物的主要成分是选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂，或称SSRI，用于治疗抑郁症、焦虑症和创伤后应激障碍。虽然帕罗西汀是一种广受欢迎的药物，当正确
correctly, it is also very potent. Several studies have linked the medication to an increase in suicidal thoughts and behaviors in certain individuals who use it. In Macedonia, there was a certain stigma surrounding mental health, especially in more traditional communities like Kichevo. Despite peroxatine being proven to be effective in treating a range of mental health issues, many avoided seeking treatment out of fear of being judged by family members, neighbours, or co-workers. Vlado Taneski had faced a difficult and challenging period from 2002 onwards after the unexpected death of both his parents, followed closely by the loss of his long-term job, but he never sought medical help from his doctor. In Macedonia, peroxatine was available
服用时有许多健康益处，但它也非常效力强大。一些研究将该药物与某些使用它的个体的自杀想法和行为的增加联系起来。在马其顿，围绕心理健康存在着一定的社会耻辱感，尤其是在基切沃这样更传统的社区。尽管帕罗西汀已被证明在治疗一系列心理健康问题方面很有效，但许多人为了避免被家人、邻居或同事评头论足而避免寻求治疗。弗拉多·塔内斯基从2002年开始经历了一段艰难且充满挑战的时期，他的双亲意外去世，紧接着他又失去了长期工作，但他从未向医生寻求医疗帮助。在马其顿，帕罗西汀是
over the counter, and Taneski had been purchasing it without a prescription. Therefore, it was unknown how long he had been taking the medication for, and whether or not it could have influenced his decision to end his life. Due to Macedonia's criminal law against prosecuting a deceased person, in September 2008, officials confirmed that the investigation into the murders of Mitra Semyonowska, Ubica Likowska, and Zavana Temelkowska was officially closed. There were still many people unconvinced of Taneski's guilt. Daniela Trupchevska, a crime reporter from Macedonia's Morning Herald newspaper, stated, police said it was suicide. Others, like me, don't think so, and I'm not 100% convinced that Vlado
非处方药，塔内斯基一直在没有处方的情况下购买它。因此，目前尚不清楚他服用这种药物多久了，以及它是否可能影响了他结束自己生命的决定。由于马其顿禁止起诉已故人员的刑法，2008年9月，官员们证实，对米特拉·塞米奥诺夫斯卡、乌比卡·利科夫斯卡和扎瓦纳·泰梅尔科斯卡谋杀案的调查正式关闭。仍有许多人对塔内斯基的清白不以为然。马其顿《晨报》的犯罪记者达妮埃拉·特鲁普切夫斯卡表示：“警方说是自杀。其他人，比如我，并不这么认为，而且我也没有100%确信弗拉多
was the killer, either. After all, he never stood trial. Sometimes I think maybe he really did it. Maybe he killed those poor women, and he had some awful desire or need to write about it. But then again, he didn't seem like he could harm anyone, let alone be a serial killer. In an interview with journalist Dmitry Kanarov for Literary Magazine Virginia Quarterly Review, Vlado Taneski's widow Vesna continued to stick by her husband, believing him to be innocent. She explained, And tell them I haven't done anything wrong. One day, things will be cleared up. Many others staunchly disagreed, pointing out that Taneski published information in his articles
也是凶手。毕竟，他从未受审。有时我想也许他真的做了。也许他杀害了那些可怜的女性，并且有一种可怕的欲望或需要去写它。但话又说回来，他看起来不像是能伤害任何人的人，更不用说成为连环杀手了。”在接受《文学杂志弗吉尼亚季刊评论》记者德米特里·卡纳罗夫采访时，弗拉多·塔内斯基的遗孀维斯娜继续坚持她丈夫的清白，相信他是无辜的。她解释说：“并告诉他们我没有做错任何事。总有一天，事情会水落石出的。”许多其他人强烈反对，指出塔内斯基在他的文章中发表了
that only the killer could know, while also arguing that Taneski's DNA found on the bodies of the victims proved without doubt that he was responsible for their deaths. A police spokesperson said, The results are absolutely categorical. It was a 100% match. It's unfortunate for us that because the suspect died, the case will never go to trial, and our evidence cannot be presented in court. In 2001, the Macedonian Institute for Media established a journalistic code of ethics in accordance with the Constitution of the Republic of Macedonia. The code states that the main duty of the journalist is to respect the truth and the right of the public to be informed,
只有凶手才知道的信息，同时还认为塔内斯基在受害者尸体上发现的DNA毫无疑问地证明了他对她们的死负有责任。一名警方发言人说：“结果是绝对确定的。这是一个100%的匹配。对我们来说不幸的是，由于嫌疑人死了，案件将永远不会开庭审判，我们的证据也无法在法庭上出示。”2001年，马其顿媒体研究所根据马其顿共和国宪法制定了一套新闻道德准则。该准则规定，记者的主要职责是尊重真相和公众获知真相的权利，
while striving to prevent censorship and distortion of news. Journalists are required to respect ethical values and professional standards, while reporting honestly and objectively at all times. The code specifically states, Having in mind their role in the building of democracy and civic society, journalists shall defend human rights, dignity and freedom. In an interview with Esquire magazine, Vesna Taneski spoke of her late husband's love for his chosen profession, saying journalism was something he couldn't live without. If he was given an assignment, he would drop everything. Whenever he was working, he would rub his hands together and be so happy. However, many former colleagues dispute Taneski's
同时努力防止审查和扭曲新闻。记者必须尊重伦理价值观和职业标准，同时始终诚实客观地进行报道。该准则明确规定：“鉴于记者在建设民主和公民社会中的作用，他们应捍卫人权、尊严和自由。”在接受《时尚先生》杂志采访时，维斯娜·塔内斯基谈到了她已故丈夫对自己选择的职业的热爱，称新闻是他生命中不可或缺的一部分。如果给他派发任务，他会放下一切。每当他工作时，他都会搓着双手，非常高兴。然而，许多前同事对塔内斯基的
journalistic integrity, claiming that throughout his career, his writing was full of cliches and often didn't satisfy the basic journalistic structure or standards. As stated by Dr. Mamoza Restova, a science professor specializing in forensics at Skopje University, quote, Vlado Taneski didn't have a source for much of the information in his reports. The only source he had was himself. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
新闻诚信提出异议，声称在他的整个职业生涯中，他的写作充满了陈词滥调，并且经常无法满足基本的新闻结构或标准。正如斯科普里大学专门研究法医的科学教授马莫扎·雷斯特娃博士所说：“弗拉多·塔内斯基在他的许多报道中没有信息来源。他唯一的来源就是他自己。”本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。